have you ever had any other traumatic
experiences on set I just did on what
I just shot a movie called the elevation
uh who's in it
we were it it
sounds Preposterous but it's really
actually awesome it's set
uh above 8 000 feet it's at a time where
there are these bugs these things kind
of catch out of the earth and sort of
just annihilating people and if you live
above 8 000 feet they can't go above
that and so there's this refuge and you
know we've been living like this for
years and I'm a scientist and I'm trying
to and I'm trying to figure out
how we kill these things and we have to
go on this journey me and Anthony Mackey
to the hospital
um because he needs something for his
kid who's got an illness and I need to
go to my lab to get the thing that's
going to help us figure out how to kill
these things and
through this journey obviously we
encounter them we run we are you know
it's it's really cool and one of the
things that we have to do
um we're on a ski run and we're trying
to get out we're trying to get above 8
000 feet as fast as possible we decide
to use the ski lift and but these things
start knocking down the lines and the
thing like drops like we're in a ski
lift that is in the film it's supposed
to be like I don't know 30 feet in the
air or something and then it just like
drops down obviously they weren't going
to put us on a ski lift and drop us 30
feet but on the Sound Stage they rigged
this whole thing and they
put us up there or
20 feet I don't actually know how many
feet but then it drops
and
I was not prepared like I don't do
roller coasters I don't do fast rides
like I have severe anxiety but I don't
Skydive I
okay
just going for a run
right
I'm on the scale left and they're like
we're just gonna drop you
and it'll be fine and then you have to
jump out but only when after it stops
swinging and I'm like so much
information the thing drops I felt my
stomach inside my mouth I was like oh my
God and ebk was running
and I literally turned
were you serious
yes I was Siri
so it's great
I'm not shaking oh my God but you did it
again
one more time who was the director this
guy George nolfe
wow you know I I I I'm sure this is
going to be great elevation when is it
out
um I don't know it's an indie so we are
they're still they're still
you know putting it together and there's
still some special effects I need to go
in so probably a little while but it's
gonna be cool